[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on Mondays Dancing with the Stars Mark
Ballas and Lindsey Stirling delivered a
sci-fi themed Argentine tango that was
futuristic and fierce I am so thrilled
that dance felt so good when I hit the
the ground at the end I was like oh we
nailed it they're so great we top this
how do we take this to the top I think
we top this by not trying to top it I
think we just have to move on to the
next week and just bring something new
and different Halloween week so they're
you know the show loves to go full-out
we're gonna have a complete different
style so just kind of letting each week
be its own thing now everyone is talking
about how it's week six always in week
six everyone starts breaking down
emotionally crying who's the therapist
here Oh Marc is a hundred percent Arabic
bless his heart you know I just don't I
care a lot a Kerala and like last week
was probably the week and the week
before that was the most memorable year
week so I've had it you know Marc was my
therapist during the most memorable year
week and I can't imagine having a better
supportive and more talented partner
[Music]